bonjour et merci d'être avec nous ce
matin en direct sur rt france alors une
nouvelle journée de manifestations
contre le pouvoir en place
pendant combien de temps encore ce bras
de fer entre les manifestants et les
militaires peuvent-ils et peut-il durer
vu comment la cité civile a montré sa
détermination
et sa capacité à la mobilisation malgré
que le pouvoir en place général brawn a
essayé de diviser cette dynamique
citoyenne en naissant d'isoler le
premier ministre et de ses anciens
partisans cette démonstration de force
marqué et a montré que la société civile
encore des réserves et sa capacité à
mobiliser et ce qui est aussi
intéressant à voir c'est que ce n'est
pas seulement à khartoum c'est
pratiquement à la moitié du pays s'est
mobilisé c'est la montre que le bras de
fer va continuer et va s'intensifier le
fait que malgré le blocage de toutes les
villes malgré la présence massive des
parcs de sécurité ces manifestants ont
réussi à arriver jusque devant le palais
présidentiel dont c'est la montre très
bien que le plus l'acheter civils
revient malgré le coup de gueule car ici
on parle à la stratégie du pouvoir en
place à les diviser à les isoler les uns
les autres alors le soudan qui a
commémoré le 19 décembre dernier le
troisième anniversaire de la révolution
qui a renversé armoires la déchire le
président de l'époque
l'histoire peut-elle se répéter selon
vous
oui comment la junte au pouvoir est en
train de planifier sa confiscation du
pouvoir parce qu'il faut le dire tous
les actes posés par roanne et le général
khan et y montre très bien que ils n'ont
pas l'intention de rendre le pouvoir aux
civils en tout cas dans le délai que que
la révolution a souhaité ou les réunions
la communauté internationale a souhaité
c'est à dire en juillet 2023 si la
tension augmente aussi les répressions
comme on a vu la répression de cette
dernière manifestation et de la
répression
de là il ya une semaine nous ça fait des
morts et des blessés cette détermination
de l'armée et cette violence
disproportionnée que ces deux sets je
n'utilise 60 que le délai que la
communauté internationale souhaite ou la
substitution pour que ces pouvoirs que
c'est de transférer au civil ne pourra
pas été respectée par les militaires
le soudan qui est voisin de l'egypte là
bas aussi on sait que voilà les
militaires ont pris le pouvoir
qu'ils ont promis aussi également de
rendre à des civils on voit que ce n'est
pas le cas
pourtant vous dit que oui c'est possible
avec la détermination des soudanais mais
dans le passé plusieurs pays qui ont été
secoué par des révolutions avec après l
arrivée au pouvoir
parfois deux militaires n'ont finalement
pas réussi à imposer à un pouvoir civil
en effet la situation géopolitique
sécuritaire
régionale a fait que la communauté
internationale était à peu près à
concentrer sur d'autres champs de
bataille le champ de contenir le jeu non
maintenant on va très bien que la
situation en ethiopie se stabilise la
situation au mali se stabilise malgré
que la tension dans la région du darfour
comment ça encore
recommencé était 5e nationale parce que
tant que la communauté internationale
est préoccupé par la situation régionale
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont plus
conciliants avec ce qui se passe souvent
ça veut dire qu'ils ont besoin de la
stabilité de ce temps pour pouvoir gérer
d'autres problèmes mais cela ne va pas
durer étant donné que la situation en
egypte s'est stabilisé la situation des
képis s'est stabilisé le darfour ce
n'est pas encore ça s'est pas développée
mais c'est encore embryonnaire cela
permettra à la société civile de pouvoir
encore mobilisés à la diaspora et aux
organisations internationales qui
soutiennent la cité steevy soudanaises à
revenir un peu au devant de la scène
mais ce qui est intéressant à voir dans
la veillée de ses mouvements c'est
comment la société civile réussira à se
réconcilier que l'argile control le
conseil militaire
l'armée essaie d'imposer un gouvernement
à son image et à sa volonté
soit pas une réalité civile a toujours
un levier pour s'imposer
oui le déficit pour l'acheter civile
morgane et ses bras de fer c'est arrivé
à se réconcilier avec le premier
ministre ainsi ils vont revenir à la
case de départ avec les mêmes forces et
avec deux côtés et n'oubliez pas madame
il ya aussi un réseau de l'ombre de
l'ancien régime ceux qui ont tout perdu
et qui veulent revenir au devant de la
scène mais ne marque pas d'efforts pour
jouer cette transition donc ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui at war son action la
société civile les jeunes militaires et
les anciens régimes qui sont dans
l'ombre istanbul
mais non c'est à la société civile
de faire en sorte que ces militaires est
la
dernière question très rapidement
comment justement
établir ce dialogue comment essayer de
les mettre à la table des discussions la
société civile et les militaires qui
sont au pouvoir
c'est simple la société civile ne veut
que le respect de ce qui a été signé
dans le dialogue
existe le procès soit mixte civile et
militaire nico b
c que les militaires c'est le plein pot
et que c'est eux qui décident le
gouvernement et la sécurité
civile
et ceux qui refusent de l'armée l'armée
parce que j'ai l'impression que l'on met
toujours la pression de concession
la communauté africaine de la
concession pression
militaire
la communauté internationale a intérêt
plutôt à mettre la pression sur les
militaires pour les amener sur le chemin
apaisé enfin que le transfert du pouvoir
il se passe des façons apaisé merci
beaucoup en tout cas à des crimes contre
goumiers d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur
associé au groupe afrique de lips
l'institut prospective sécurité en
europe